Professor John Rogers:
Readers typically finish
the last books of Paradise
Lost with -- I don't know,
I certainly had this experience
the first time I read it and,
I think, actually many times
since then -- with something
like a sense of disappointment,
and the disappointment that has
traditionally accompanied these
last books is usually associated
with the question of their
style.
Michael's prophetic vision of
future history is laid out
before Adam with -- and you get
this sense -- with a kind of
labored and painstaking
didacticism.
We so miss Raphael, I think.
The affable Raphael had charmed
us with that endearing
uncertainty that he had about
the structure of the cosmos,
for example.
Was Ptolemy right?
Was Copernicus right?
Who cares?
Raphael made an art out of his
uncertainty, and he seemed to
place his blessing thereby on
all of the ambiguities and all
of the ambivalences and
uncertainties that filled nearly
every line of the poem.
But everything,
or nearly everything,
changes with the appearance of
the Archangel Michael.
Michael's speech is much less
open -- there's no question
about this -- to a proliferation
of signifying possibilities.
He speaks in labored,
declarative sentences and his
purpose seems above all to
provide Adam with a powerful
sense of his culpability,
Adam's culpability,
for the hell that is future
history.
I mean actually hell quite
literally because there's an
important way in which the last
two books of Paradise Lost
provide us with a kind of
mirror of the first two books.
The catalog of fallen history
that we have at the poem's
conclusion reproduces and
rehearses a lot of the patterns
of behavior that were
established in the first two
books.
David's lecture on Friday has
made me think of the ways in
which sometimes what seems to be
the futility of human action and
human behavior in the last two
books also harkens back to an
earlier time even before the
events recounted in Books One
and Two -- and that's,
of course, the war in heaven.
The pointlessness of the war in
heaven on some level gets
reproduced in -- in the sense
that we have sometimes of-- the
pointlessness of life [laughs]
after the Fall in the last
couple of books of the
poem.But like the war in
heaven,
there is a kind of heroism
that's possible in the last two
books of Paradise Lost.
I won't be talking about
this at any length,
but it's an important part of
Milton's conception of history
and it's often referred to as
Milton's "one just man" theory
of history.
Every generation seems to have
one man who is willing to stand
alone and stand apart from the
corruption of the crowd,
and that man will do everything
he possibly can -- on some level
it's still going to be futile --
to advance the civilization and
the level of spiritual
excellence of the people that
much further.
The one just man in the war in
heaven was, of course,
the angel Abdiel with whom
Milton himself felt himself so
identified.Well,
in any case, think of Book Ten.
Book Ten had been filled with a
catalog of the punishments that
Adam and Eve had to endure as a
consequence of their behavior,
but it seems at times as if the
harshest punishment of all that
comes as a consequence of the
Fall will be Adam's subjection
to the catechism of Michael in
Books Eleven and Twelve.
Adam is subjected to an
instructor, an instructor whose
grim sense of humor,
whose abrasive sarcasm,
and whose unfeeling didacticism
all contribute,
at least to my mind,
to a sensibility utterly
foreign to that of the first
[laughs]
ten books.
If we as the sons and daughters
of Adam and Eve are to be
punished, it seems as if we,
too, are to be punished for
that original sin.
How are we punished?
We're punished because if we
want to finish this stupid poem
we have an obligation to read
and experience Michael's
uncompromising pedagogy,
his teaching of Adam.Now,
the literary style of the last
books may be that aspect of them
that first incites our
disappointment,
but it's certainly not the only
disappointing element of those
books.
We're also disappointed with
the actual content -- I'm
disappointed with the content of
Michael's history.
I will continually be harkening
back to Raphael who seems so
much more affable in retrospect
than maybe he did at the time.
We remember Raphael's teasing
account of future history in
Book Five.
You'll remember this.
If Adam and Eve could only
remain sinless,
if they could only remain
obedient,
then their future might consist
of that grand but slow
transmutation into the ethereal
matter of angels.
It was really quite beautiful,
but Adam and Eve,
of course, did not remain
sinless and their future history
necessarily has to look
disappointingly different from
that natural history that
Raphael had been able to
anticipate.Now most critics,
most Milton scholars writing
about the last two books of
Milton's poem have invested
their time -- and you can
understand why this is necessary
-- have invested their time in
defending books Eleven and
Twelve,
and there's a certain kind of
nervousness about the
unpleasantness of the conclusion
of this poem.
Critics are continually -- and
I think this is misguided,
but I understand it nonetheless
-- they're continually
attempting to shelter the poem
from the accusation that its
ending represents something like
a disappointing falling off.
Now I think these critics are
right, they're absolutely right,
to insist that the last books
are supremely artful creations
-- that's undeniable -- and that
Milton displays in them his
sophisticated engagement of
biblical history and of
theology.
Milton takes extraordinary care
in crafting the process of the
education to which Adam is
subjected in the last books.
That said, I think it's a
mistake, or I'm convinced it's a
mistake, to deny the fact that
these books are,
in addition to all of that,
disappointing.
So I think we can profitably
examine why it is that Milton
ends his poem with these last
books,
Michael's severe treatise on
scriptural history.Now,
these last books mark Milton's
only attempt in Paradise Lost
to represent what we would
think of as actual human
history.
In order to understand why this
section of the poem is so
troubled and so worrisome,
we have to understand Milton's
own brush with history,
his own participation in the
disappointing history of the
failed Puritan Revolution.
Now Milton has taken great
pains to keep from his poem
anything like a direct allusion
to the political turmoil of his
own day,
but what I am hoping I'll be
able to do, at least for a few
minutes here,
is to show one of the ways in
which Michael's treatment of
scriptural history is still
intimately connected to the
contemporary political history
that Milton was himself enmeshed
in.Now,
you may have noticed that the
work of Milton's political prose
by far that I have most
consistently cited over the
course of these lectures -- or
written little things on the
board [laughs]
in quotation of it -- is
Areopagitica,
the speech against
licensing that Milton had
printed in 1644.
There's a way in which that
exuberant liberalism of
Areopagitica was
continually resurfacing in the
most interesting and,
in a lot of cases,
the most daring passages of the
entire poem.
We remember instances in which
Belial and, at another point,
Eve seemed to be actually
alluding to Areopagitica
or certainly reproducing
arguments that Milton had made
there,
and so I devoted a lot of
attention to
Areopagitica;
but in doing so I think I've
also distorted,
maybe kind of drastically,
the truth about Milton's
political sensibility in the
very years that he was writing
Paradise
Lost.Milton's epic poem
appeared over twenty years,
or twenty-three years,
after the treatise on
licensing;
I've given you a sketch of this
history before,
but it's worth looking at at
another time.
In the mid 1640s,
Milton was really at the height
of what we can think of as his
liberalism, even though that
word wasn't yet in existence.
Milton was wildly optimistic
about the success of what he
felt to be the Puritan
Revolution,
and he seemed genuinely
confident that something like a
rational, spiritual,
Puritan utopia could actually
be established on English soil.
At the center of his political
optimism was his faith in the
political category that Milton
called "the people."
When he was writing in Latin,
he would use the Latin for
people,
which is populus.
Throughout the 1640s,
up to 1650, Milton was
confident, really exuberantly
confident,
that God had infused the power
of reason and virtue into every
single human individual and that
this God-given capacity for
reason and virtue would enable
the English people,
the populus,
to govern themselves in an
entirely non-authoritarian,
almost completely egalitarian
political structure.I think
you can see most dramatically --
and this is a treatise that we
haven't read in this course,
but it's included in the
Hughes -- you can see
this faith in the self-rule of
the people in Milton's 1649
treatise,
really the greatest of all of
what we call the regicide
treatises: The Tenure of
Kings and Magistrates,
in which Milton
actually actively advocates the
regicide.
There's almost a sense in
The Tenure of Kings and
Magistrates that you don't
even really need any kind of
formal governmental structure at
all.
The people are actually going
to be able to govern themselves
without any other
edifice.There turned out to
be a problem,
however, with Milton's
political idealism,
and that problem no doubt
involved the fact that Milton's
political idealism seemed to
have had no basis whatsoever in
reality.
Milton may have been convinced
that God had infused every
single human individual with
this power of rational
self-rule,
but the actual people,
the actual populus of
England, turned out not to be so
easily convinced.
The real English people
themselves were considerably
more conservative than the small
Puritan elite who had pushed for
the execution of Charles the
First in 1649 and who had placed
themselves at the head of the
new,
non-monarchic,
republican government.
If anything,
the majority of the English
people themselves were in favor
of monarchy,
and so Milton found himself,
as so often,
compelled to modify his own
political idealism.
By 1650, Milton wasn't able to
say that the English should be
governed by the people -- by
1651,
I should say,
he was no longer able to say
that, that on some level the
people obviously couldn't be
trusted any longer to get it
right.So he had to weaken
his claim that the people were
all rational and self-governing.
He began to forward a much less
idealistic principle of
government, and that was the
government of England by a small
elected body of people called
Parliament.
Parliament had existed well
before Milton,
before this new turn in
Milton's political philosophy,
but Milton was placing an
entirely new importance on this
body.
So maybe the people themselves
aren't all that rational and
virtuous and self-determining,
capable of self-government,
but surely Parliament -- this
is the new turn in Milton's
thinking -- an elite group of
the people,
can be counted on to uphold
Milton's own value of rational
self-determination and rational
self-rule.Well,
the republican decade wears on,
the 1650s, and by the time we
get to the end of the decade,
the kingless government of
England -- under the rule of
Oliver Cromwell and later under
the rule of Cromwell's son --
this republican government is
getting closer and closer to a
complete collapse.
There's a widespread popular
movement: it's a movement
fomented by the people seeking
the return of the Stuart
monarchy,
and this time it's not only the
common people who are calling
for the return of their king.
It's also Parliament who has --
from Milton's perspective,
Parliament has entirely sold
out;
and so by late 1659,
there is a majority now even in
Parliament desiring -- this is
again Milton's construction of
it -- desiring to re-subject the
English people to the tyranny of
monarchy.So in 1659 when
Milton is writing his final
political treatise,
he's compelled to alter his
views once again,
and he finds very little
evidence of the rational,
virtuous, ethical principles
that he had been so confident
about in Areopagitica,
this idea that all human
individuals possess the virtue
and the reason and the spirit
that he had previously
attributed to them.
It starts to seem as if all men
are actually not created equal
and that very few of them have
anything like divine virtue or
divine reason infused into them
by God.
So now the people that Milton
had once so wonderfully and
movingly idealized,
he's able to refer to -- and
it's really kind of jarring and,
just frankly,
it's depressing -- Milton's now
able to refer to the people as
the -- and I'm quoting here
–
"the rude and inconsiderate
multitude," the unruly mob.
You have a whole elaborate
lexicon of invectives concerning
the people in the last political
treatises of Milton's.Milton
imagines,
because he can't even count on
Parliament -- he comes to insist
that the unruly and irrational
English,
these masses,
are ungovernable even by
Parliament.
So the governing body is going
to have to be an even smaller
group, a collection of England's
most rational and most spiritual
men,
men of course,
who look exactly like John
Milton himself:
so a group of men more
excellent than the far-too-large
mass of people that constitute
Parliament.
You have something like what's
essentially a spiritual elite.
This spiritual elite would have
to govern England,
and Milton thinks of them as a
council of saints;
he refers to them as a council
of saints.
So in a little more than a
decade this political idealist
has shifted from his celebration
of the power and the liberty due
to the people to a depressingly
shriveled sense -- and it is
pretty shrunk and pretty pitiful
thing -- of the power and
liberty only due to a very small
group of like-minded Puritan
revolutionaries.So a lot of
the liberal confidence of a work
like Areopagitica just
disappears by the time we get to
Milton's late political prose.
Just how depressing this shift
is will become clear to you when
-- have I assigned The Ready
and Easy Way to Establish a Free
Commonwealth on the
syllabus?
I may have taken it off this
year because I did not want to
depress you, but you should not
let my attempt to protect you
from what might seem the ugliest
parts of Milton from taking
advantage of Hughes's inclusion
of that important and
interesting text in your
edition.
Milton will argue in The
Ready and Easy Way that he
wrote in 1659 that this new
spiritual council,
the council of saints,
they should actually be
permitted to deploy military
force if necessary to subject
the unruly masses to their will.
This is how the argument goes,
and it's a disconcerting one:
the people are now so little to
be trusted that they have to be
forced to recognize,
at gunpoint if necessary,
their God-given liberty and
their God--;[laughs]
given capacity for self-rule.
Of course, it goes without
question there's a horrible
paradox there.
Milton seems to be arguing that
the people will govern
themselves -- goddammit!
-- even if they have to be
forced to do it.So this
final plan -- this is Milton's
final political scheme -- is
something like a junta of
Puritan saints.
Of course, the scheme was never
enacted.
Shortly after Milton proposed
it, the republican government
completely collapsed in early
1660,
and Charles the Second,
the dead king's son,
was returned to the throne and
monarchy was restored.
And Milton -- think about the
position that he's in.
Milton was actually placed in
prison for a while for his
writings against the king,
and he was generally living in
some degree of poverty and
certainly in disgrace.All of
this is a very long-winded way
of saying we have come a long
way by the time we get actually
to the composition of
Paradise Lost.
We've come a very long way
from the moving idealism of
Areopagitica.
Milton has endured an
entire decade of political
disappointment and I think it's
possible to see the relation
between the fall of Milton's own
political idealism over the
course of a decade and a half or
so and the fall of man as it's
represented in Paradise Lost.
Milton's able to use the
narrative of the fall of
paradise in some way,
I think,
to map his own experience with
the loss of the English
commonwealth,
the English commonwealth that
Milton had really seen as
something like a paradise of
Puritan saints.You could
think of Adam and Eve after the
Fall,
in a lot of ways at least,
as a version of the English
people for Milton in the late
1650s.
They show surprisingly few
signs of internalized divine
reason and internalized virtue,
and so this is why -- at least,
I think this is why Milton has
to introduce into his narrative
this irritable Archangel
Michael,
and this is why Milton stages
this scene of angelic
instruction so differently from
the way he staged the scene with
Raphael.
I only need to mention Eve's
role in all of this.
Eve, you'll remember,
decided on her own not to stick
around for Raphael's lessons in
astronomy.
She'd just as soon learn it,
she told us,
[laughs]
later from Adam,
whose pedagogy was a little
more interesting than Raphael's
because Adam interspersed his
lessons with kisses.
That was Eve's choice,
and Milton goes out of his way
to represent that as Eve's
choice;
but after the Fall,
Eve is not given that choice.
She's forced to absent herself
here and Adam,
who gets to stay -- it's not
clear what kind of privilege
that is -- is subjected to the
severity of Michael's teaching
on some level because he can't
be trusted to behave as a
rational,
self-governing individual after
the Fall.
Someone is going to have to
teach him, and in fact teach him
quite forcefully,
how to understand life in the
fallen world.So Michael
enters onto the scene and -- I
think this is his goal,
at least -- to instill in Adam
the powers of reason and virtue.
He does this by means of a
history lesson,
something that before the Fall,
Adam seems to have possessed
instinctively -- or rather,
it was a kind of reason and
virtue that he possessed
instinctively,
but now it needs to be
instilled.
Michael presents Adam with the
sweep of Christian history and
with the promise of man's
eventual redemption from the
Fall,
and it's this entire lesson
that Adam is going to have to
internalize, literally take in
to himself.
The last two books of
Paradise Lost,
I think in a lot of ways,
represent something like a
drama of internalization.
One of the important aspects of
these books is what they have to
tell us, I think,
about the complicated
psychological process of the
internalization of any kind of
authoritative wisdom.So
we're finally now in a position
actually to look at the poem.
Look at page 442 in the
Hughes. This is Book
Eleven, line 411.
Michael's history lesson is
really quite extraordinarily,
carefully organized.
It's broken up into two
discrete sections,
books Eleven and Twelve,
and these two discrete sections
proceed along entirely distinct
lines.
The first half of the lesson,
which takes us up to the moment
of God's destruction of the
world with Noah's flood,
is presented to Adam as a
vision, and Adam sees this early
history unfold itself.
This is something that comes to
him through the access of his
eyes.
The second half of the lesson,
which is the entirety of the
lesson as it exists in Book
Twelve, is not presented to Adam
visually at all.
Michael simply describes it to
Adam.
He relates it in the form of a
narrative.This shift from
vision to narrative has
everything,
I think, to do with the
psychological process of
internalization that Milton is
exploring in the last books.
I think it has everything to do
as well with the shift in
literary style to which Milton
subjects the ending of his great
epic.
The turn to the new style of
books Eleven and Twelve is in a
lot of ways analogous to
Michael's turn to didactic
narrative in Book Twelve after
the grand tableaus,
after all of the visual
splendor that he has conjured in
the visions -- the masques the
tableau vivant
essentially -- that Michael
presents to Adam in Book XI.
This new style is geared even
more intensely toward the
project of internalization.
It places a greater and greater
burden on Adam and certainly on
the reader to ascertain its
significance.Traditionally,
the truths of history could
actually be seen,
but eventually,
by the time we get to Book
Twelve,
they can only be heard.
Adam has to become increasingly
active in his own education.
So let's look first at the
visionary aspect of Book Eleven.
I don't know what to do with
this passage.
This is line 411:
Michael leads Adam to the top
of the highest hill in paradise,
a hill so high -- explain this
to me -- that Adam can see the
location of every great Western
city that will come to establish
itself in future years,
but simply seeing all of these
locations isn't sufficient.
Michael's pedagogy has to be
more thoroughgoing even than
that, and so he inspires Adam to
see the actual scenes of history
unfold themselves before his
eyes.
This is what we're told at line
411:
…
[B]ut to nobler sights
Michael from Adam's eyes the
Film remov'd
Which that false Fruit that
promis'd clearer sight
Had bred;
then purg'd [Michael having
purged Adam's eyes]
with
Euphrasy and Rue
The visual Nerve,
for he had much to see;
And from the Well of Life three
drops instill'd.
So deep the power of these
Ingredients pierc'd,
Ev'n to the inmost seat of
mental sight,
That Adam now enforc't to close
his eyes,
Sunk down and all his Spirits
became intranst…
There's something about the
ophthalmological specificity
about this passage that really
gets me.
This account of what Milton is
telling us was actually done to
Adam's eyes in order to allow
him to see the unfolding of
Christian history.
The ingestion of the forbidden
fruit seems to have weakened his
eyesight, and so the new film
that has come to cover over
Adam's eyes has to be purged
with these herbs,
Euphrasy and Rue.
Michael goes even further than
that and adds for good measure
three drops from the well of
life in order to permit Adam to
see in his mind's eye sights
impossible even before the
Fall.This scene of
inspiration,
I think, is strange,
but of course it has a powerful
charge for us,
not least because for so much
of the poem the poet himself has
claimed to be inspired in his
composition of the poem,
and we know this:
Milton was blind and he was
convinced that something -- or
at least this is the William
Kerrigan argument that I
exfoliated for you all -- he was
convinced that something that he
had eaten had on some level been
responsible for the vaporous
film that seemed to have covered
his eyes.
In the invocation to Book
Three, you'll remember Milton
bids the muse Urania to purge
him of that film:
"all mist from thence / purge
and disperse,
that I may see and tell / of
things invisible to mortal
sight."
Milton's clearly drawing a
connection here between his own
inspiration to write Paradise
Lost and Adam's preparation
to witness the vision that is
future Christian
history.That much,
I think, is clear,
but what exactly does this
connection mean?
What is the relation between
Michael's vision in Book XI and
the inspired epic poem that
Urania -- the heavenly muse,
the heavenly spirit,
or whatever we're supposed to
call that entity -- that this
entity helps Milton to write?
I welcome other possibilities,
but I think the relation seems
to be something like an ironic
one,
and that irony is suggested,
I think, by the weird chemical
exactitude of Milton's
description of Adam's
inspiration.
We have an actual scene of
medically induced inspiration at
the very moment that the
inspiration of the poem itself
seems to have been lost and
comes to a stop,
the loss of innocence that has
brought with it the loss of
Milton's -- or what I think we
were associating with and
identifying as Milton's --
inspired poetry.Milton
carefully crafts his account,
I think, of this vision of
poetry in a poetic style that
can only with great difficulty
be described as inspired.
It's these last two books are
amazing works of art,
but we don't have anything like
that extravagant and dramatic
rhetorical lushness that had so
characterized the previous ten
books.
What you have in Book Eleven is
Milton's enactment,
in some way,
of the birth of what we can
think of as modern poetry,
a poetry that's been purged of
excess and purged of all of that
open-ended figuration.
Think of the Renaissance and
the literature of Spenser and
Shakespeare.
The Renaissance called the
amplitude of its great writers
copia.
We no longer have that copia
here in the last two books.
We have a poetics that is given
to Puritan austerity and simple
declarations of moral facts,
and you will see that the
poetic mode of Paradise
Regained and,
in fact,
the poetic mode of a lot of
later poets -- I'm thinking of
the discursive poetry of a
Romantic poet like Wordsworth --
has been heavily influenced by
the last two books of
Paradise Lost.So Adam
has to be chemically induced to
see future Christian history
because all other inspiration in
the poem is no longer operative.
Adam has to be compelled,
literally compelled,
to see how this history unfolds
itself in the manner of little
pageants and little skits.
He has to see it,
of course, because he's not
able at this stage in his
development to understand its
import through the non-visual
faculty of imagination.
I think Milton,
the inspired prophet,
has an incredibly and
troublingly complicated relation
to Adam at this point -- Adam,
who is so uninspired in this
poem that Milton has claimed to
be so overly inspired to write
in the first place.
My guess is that the blind
poet, Milton,
is actually scornful on some
level of the fact that Adam has
to be inspired merely to see the
events of future years.
Milton's own prophetic powers
presumably entirely transcended
the entire category of the
visual.Okay,
let's move on.
Look at the top of page 446 in
the Hughes.
This is Book Eleven,
line 556.
This is Milton's description
[laughs]
of the cities of the plain that
Adam sees,
and the emphasis is everywhere
in this account on those things
that can be discerned through
acts of visual perception.
So line 556:
He look'd and saw a
spacious Plain,
whereon
Were Tents of various hue;
by some were herds
Of Cattel grazing:
others, whence the sound
Of Instruments that made
melodious chime
Was heard, of Harp and
Organ…
And here Milton goes on to
describe the player of that
organ;
this is the first human
musician.
Presumably, this is the first
human artist of any kind.
He hears the chime but also:
[W]ho mov'd
Thir stops and chords was seen:
his volant touch
Instinct through all
proportions low and high
Fled and pursu'd transverse the
resonant fugue.
Now we might reasonably expect
that Milton's one and only
representation of a human
musician in the poem,
a figure whose artistic touch
is a lot like Milton's,
"instinct through all
proportions low and high" -- we
might expect that this would
appear in a favorable context.
Why would we not?
But, as in so many [laughs]
other instances throughout
these final books,
Milton,
who has so absolutely become
our stereotype of him as the
humorless Puritan,
is turning on -- he's really
betraying the very art of sound
that constitutes one of his
poem's greatest achievements.
There has to be something
self-wounding here in this
derogation of music,
and I don't care that it's
fallen music.Nonetheless,
this is beautiful music that
Milton knows that he's
representing here,
but the beautiful music of the
organ is nonetheless
inextricably linked to the Fall.
The organist's fingers flee and
pursue the resonant fugue just
as Adam and Eve will soon be
fleeing paradise,
pursued, of course,
by a band of armed cherubim.
Like the beautiful sounds that
are heard, beautiful sights that
are seen are necessarily
unvaryingly suspect in these
books.
It's really not until books
Eleven and Twelve that we get
the full sense of just how much
[laughs]
of a surly Puritan Milton has
become,
just how much of the
suspiciousness,
the general suspiciousness,
that the Puritans had of the
whole aesthetic category,
how much of that he has adopted
for himself.
Look down at line 580.
These men on the cities of the
plain:
Long had not walkt,
when from the Tents behold
A Beavy of fair Women,
richly gay
In Gems and wanton dress;
to the Harp they sung
Soft amorous Ditties,
and in dance [laughs]
I love this phrase and I don't
really know if it
meant then what it means now]
came on [isn't that
wonderful?]:
The Men though grave,
ey'd them, and let thir eyes
Rove without rein,
till in the amorous Net
Fast caught,
they lik'd, and each his liking
chose…
So the faculties of perception
here are nothing more than the
vehicles of deception.
They're implicated in this
endless replaying of the sexual
seduction that is now viewed,
mistakenly of course,
as the cause of the
Fall.Well,
dopey Adam here is still at an
early stage in Michael's
achingly long lesson in history.
Of course, Adam thinks that
things with his descendants are
starting to look pretty good,
and so that's what he tells
Michael at the top of page 447.
This is line 598:
"True opener of mine eyes,
prime Angel blest,
/ Much better seems this
Vision,
and more hope / Of peaceful
dayes portends,
then those two past…"
As so often -- and this is a
pattern that will repeat itself
until the book is done -- Adam
has completely missed the point
of Michael's lesson.
He mistakes the pleasant
appearance of this scene with
moral rectitude itself,
and so when Adam tells Michael,
"Much better seems this
Vision," he's really no better
than the men who live on the
plain who are eying the bevy of
fair women and letting their
eyes rove without rein.It's
the fact that this beauty is
apprehended solely through the
eyes,
solely through the senses,
that, of course,
lies at the heart of the danger
here.
Adam has to learn to exercise
his reason, and this is one of
the things that Michael gets him
to perform eventually.
All things beautiful are by
definition here suspect,
and this is one of the lessons
derived from,
I think, the most elaborate of
all of the classes that Michael
offers Adam -- and that's the
history of the great flood.
Look at page 452.
This is line 826.
This story is so important that
it's one that's actually
narrated twice.
We have first the narrator's
description of the prophetic
reenactment of the flood -- or
rather,
it's not a reenactment,
it's a pre-enactment because it
actually hasn't happened yet.
This is the version that Adam
actually sees.
Then second,
we have Michael's long,
play-by-play accounting to Adam
of what it is exactly that he
has just seen at line 826 of
Book Eleven.
This is the narrated section of
the story of the flood.
Michael is describing for Adam
the terrible rain that will undo
all of the work of the earth's
creation:
…
[A]ll fountains of the Deep
Broke up, shall heave the Ocean
to usurp
Beyond all bounds,
till inundation rise
Above the highest Hills:
then shall this Mount
Of Paradise by might of Waves
be mov'd
Out of his place,
push'd by the horned flood,
With all his verdure spoil'd,
and Trees adrift
Down the great River to the
op'ning Gulf,
And there take root an Island
salt and bare
[This line:]
The haunt of Seals and Orcs,
and Sea-mews' clang.
Michael's describing the effect
of the flood on Eden.
This is the mount of paradise,
which, like all other things,
will be moved out of its place
by the flood and washed into the
opening gulf of the
ocean.Now this particular
image teaches us a lot more than
simply the extent of this mighty
flood.
The point here is the ultimate
insignificance of all tangible
things, of anything whose beauty
we had been appreciating by our
senses.
Adam has been permitted by an
extraordinary administration of
magic eyedrops to see a scene of
future history whose point is
the vanity,
the emptiness,
of all those things that can be
seen, and the lesson is
absolutely devastating.
The garden of paradise -- whose
lush vegetation,
whose wandering rivers we have
had described for us in such
powerfully visual terms and in
such powerfully seductive verse
-- this garden will one day be
pulled into the sea where it
will "take root an Island salt
and bare,
/ the haunt of Seals and Orcs,
and Sea-mews' clang."The
effect here is not simply on our
visual memory of the vegetative
splendor of Milton's paradise:
Milton's assaulting as well our
aural memory of the sounds of
paradise,
our memory of the beauty of the
poetic verse that had produced
in us our visual sense of the
gorgeousness of the Garden of
Eden.
In the repressive Puritan
regime of the last two books,
the resonant organ tones of the
poem's earlier books also have
to be washed away.
So in that amazing line,
"the haunt of Seals and Orcs,
and Sea-mews' clang," Milton
creates an onomatopoetic line.
What does it do?
It actually enacts with a kind
of strident horror the
squawking, horrible sounds of
these sea creatures.
It offers us a sonic emblem of
the general stridency,
I think, of the concluding
books: the uncompromising tone
of severity that instructs us
not to overvalue the lush beauty
of the previous books -- not to
overvalue the beauty of paradise
but also not to overvalue the
beauty of the poetry of
Paradise Lost.Well,
a question presents itself at
this point and it's one that I
think is inescapable.
Why does Eden have to be
destroyed at all?
"Why is it washed away in
Noah's flood?"
we ask.
The paradise that was lost,
it turns out,
wasn't the significant one.
This is an incredibly important
part of Michael's lesson.
Look at how Michael explains
this at line 836:
paradise is destroyed -- he's
talking to Adam:
"To teach thee that God
attributes to place / no
sanctity,
if none be thither brought / by
Men who there frequent,
or therein dwell."
Now think of what Michael has
just said.
The Garden of Eden will become
an "Island salt and bare" at
least a thousand years after the
moment that Michael is currently
related this prophecy to Adam.
Eden will be destroyed in order
to teach Adam at this very
moment in the present time that
places aren't divine,
only the people that live in
them.This is an
extraordinarily bizarre temporal
disjunction that we have here.
Paradise isn't going to be
destroyed for another millennium
or so in the time of Noah,
but it will be destroyed in
order to make good on Michael's
prophecy of its destruction.
Paradise has to be destroyed so
that Michael's prophecy of that
event can have its proper
pedagogical effect on Adam now
in the present moment of the
narration.
Michael attempts -- it's an
amazing way to compel the
internalization of paradise by
forcing Adam to confront its
real-life destruction.Now,
at the conclusion of these
lessons in history -- this is
near the end of Book Twelve,
page 467, line 585 -- Michael
states in much more formal terms
just this lesson of
internalization.
So, "having listened to my
history," Michael tells Adam:
"hen wilt thou not be loath /
To leave this Paradise,
but shalt possess / A Paradise
within thee, happier far."
Once Adam pictures the terrible
destruction of paradise,
he'll come to understand that
an internalized paradise is
superior,
and it's a happy compensation
for the lost place of Eden.
Readers of Milton,
and certainly scholars of
Milton, have taken Michael at
his word when he tells Adam that
the paradise that dwells within
will be happier far than the
paradise in which he himself is
currently dwelling and will
soon,
of course, be forced to
leave.There's an important
sense in which we have to see
the inward paradise as the
greater and more consequential
Miltonic phenomenon.
As a radical Protestant,
Milton had always insisted on
the superiority of inward human
reason and of the inward spirit
over anything like the visual
splendor of churches or the
sanctity of so-called holy
places -- or the written codes,
for that matter,
of church doctrine.
From a doctrinal point of view,
there is no question Michael is
beyond reproach here;
but I still want to apply,
because this is what I do,
a little bit of skepticism to
this little bit of dogma.
How convincing is Michael here?
Does our learning in one line
that the paradise within us is
actually happier far -- does it
really undo our investment,
the readers' investment,
in this place,
this paradise which has been so
lovingly and so beautifully
described in the thousands of
lines that preceded it?
When Michael describes the
"Seals and Orcs and Sea-Mews'
clang" that will literally take
over the place of paradise,
can we help but look back with
regret at the liberal beauties
of this poem before this
strident archangel had taken it
over essentially -- taken the
poem into receivership with his
unyielding dogmatism?From
the aesthetic point of view,
I think Michael's discourse is
a complete disaster.
We experience it as a form of
loss, and Milton compels us as
readers, I think,
to experience along with Adam
and Eve something like the loss
of paradise.
We are compelled to undergo the
loss of what we loved about
Paradise Lost.
We are compelled to undergo
the aesthetic fall that is taken
by this very poem.
This is, I think,
Milton's way of precipitating
our internalization of his
poem.As I mentioned earlier,
in the late 1650s Milton was no
longer able to justify the
extension of political liberties
to the people.
The English people,
to his mind,
had fallen and Milton could no
longer imagine granting them the
kind of freedom of
self-determination that he had
described so rhapsodically in a
treatise like
Areopagitica.
You can see a related hardening
of sensibility really in the
last books of Paradise Lost
in the fallen reader
and the fallen poet.
We can no longer afford the
moral and theological
uncertainty that had been
fostered and really celebrated
by the sublime poetic style that
we can now call,
now that it's gone, Miltonic.
It's as if we can no longer
afford the indulgence in all of
those stylistic elements of the
earlier books that have been so
carefully purged from Michael's
lessons in history.
It's as if we can't afford to
indulge in those ethically
ambiguous similes,
the delectable allusions to the
full range of pagan classics,
and those extraordinary flights
of the poet's own original
myth-making -- all of those
elements that have made this
poem so grand but that have
continually,
as we've charted,
threatened to unhinge the story
from anything like its basis in
moral doctrine or scriptural
certainty.The poetic effect
that we have here is primarily
one of loss and it's a type of
loss that we've encountered
before in Milton.
I'm just about at my
conclusion, but I want to remind
you of Milton's first poem,
his first great poem,
the Nativity Ode of
1629.
Milton, you'll remember,
had described the triumphant
entry of Christ.
His destruction of all of the
evil pagan gods and the onset of
the Christian era was celebrated
as a joyous one;
but of course it brought with
it a loss that Milton at that
time was willing to measure.
The pagan nymphs,
you'll remember,
felt the pain of their
banishment from the beautiful
forests of classical literature:
"With flower-inwov'n tresses
torn / the Nimphs in twilight
shade of tangled thickets
mourn."
That poem of religious
celebration made a brief,
but it was potent,
detour into elegy,
and Milton seemed almost to
recognize the painfulness of the
loss of classical literature and
the loss of the poetic beauty
with which we associate
classical literature.I think
there's a related sense of loss
that attends the otherwise
triumphant conclusion of the
theological doctrine that
Michael presents at the end of
Book Twelve.
On the doctrinal level,
Michael does end on a painfully
optimistic note -- I know that's
an oxymoron but it still brings
me pain -- the way in which he
represents the promise of man's
eventual redemption.
But on an aesthetic level,
you have almost the plangency,
I think, of elegy -- a sad
consciousness of all of those
pleasures and all of those
liberties that now have to be
forsaken.Okay.
I'm ending the lecture there,
but I just want to remind you
that that, of course,
is not the end of the story.
The poem will change a final
time.
Once again, in its last hundred
lines or so you will have the
reemergence of a lot of things
that we associate with Milton.
Certainly we'll have the
reemergence of the epic simile,
which we'll pay attention to
closely on Wednesday.
So focus for the next class on
the poem's ending.